Hannah Storm SportsCenter anchor
broadcaster and part of the broadcast
team andrea kramer and hannah the amazon
prime videos live streaming coverage
eleven thursday night football games and
it started last night
not a bad debut to have that game Hannah
how did it feel last night no kidding I
mean can you believe that so many
touchdowns so much fun that Rams offense
is as a blast I mean they were scoring
so quickly so yeah I was great it was
really really fun loved it
a lot of action so I don't think he
could have dialed up a better game it
was something really slow I think it
would have been a lot tougher
okay the approach to this is there an
approach well give me your approach if
you're trying to make it different you
know it's when they approach to us they
just they wanted our sensibility they
just wanted our voices sort of you know
what you know the way we were seeing the
game so it's really interesting because
they weren't setting out to have a
quote-unquote female broadcast they
didn't like scour the country and
interview a bunch of people they
literally came to the two of us and if
we weren't going to do it they just
weren't going to do it so that was cool
right so that felt like okay this isn't
you know the first thing they said is
this isn't a gimmick we want the two of
you guys we have two English guys with
soccer backgrounds doing it you know we
have a couple of Spanish guys doing it
last year they had two Argentinian
announcers and so they're providing
different options for their customers so
you know if I had to characterize what
it was well I think it's a combination
of kind of you know it's definitely
play-by-play it's definitely the story
of the game but it's not you know play
break down play a break down play break
down you know the kind of like we're
used to watching I would say there are a
lot more stories behind it we had a ton
of conversations with people you know a
lot of the players the coaches and so
forth you know as most broadcast teams
do and talk to some other people you
know certainly about what the
competition committee was talking about
yesterday and things like that was a
roughing the passer and then we had to
you know just
a lot of background digging and research
talk to family members and some players
so sometimes you can get those stories
in in a slow game and sometimes
obviously the football takes over and
you're just you know basically talking
football the whole time you're married
to Dan Hicks who is done play-by-play
his entire career you probably like that
but what advice did your husband give
you well and the funny thing is there
you've had both of us on in one week you
might say cousin who everyone thinks I'm
actually married to is really hilarious
so yeah to you by the way Dan head or
Fred Hickman by virtue of his name so I
mean what can I say
but anyway you know deal said dan said
the same thing that actually Tirico said
to me to Cris Collinsworth to me and it
was it was have fun and be yourself and
I thought that was just a great piece of
advice and keep it simple right no I
mean the tendency to go in when you're
doing something you've never done
and some buddies don't have experience
doing is to obviously I was over
prepared for it in some way and then I
was prepared not to use anything that I
had prepared you know what I mean like
you over prepare for something and then
you don't know kind of what types of
information you really need until you
actually do it and then he just could
keep it really simple so I did I mean if
I don't know something I don't say it if
I don't try to get too fancy too
technical just I really really tried to
stay in my wheelhouse because I just
wanted to keep it a clean broadcast
definitely made you know it's one of the
things that have been you know we're
taking the Fox feed we are 3,000 miles
away and we don't know what they're
doing so you know things will pop up and
so you know sometimes you know that that
makes it awkward also you know and then
we lay out those guys come on camera
there's like all sorts of kind of things
that are unusual like we don't have
control of the telecast
all that having been said you know I
don't overextend myself I really try not
to I mean unless they really know what
I'm saying or really understand the
situation andrea is so football savvy -
you know she's it's been her whole life
and career and she can break down
coverages and you know she can talk
about the routes and talk about the
plays and I mean she's just fantastic so
I would say that we really complement
each other and we definitely lean on
each other
yeah the beauty of having Andrea Kramer
there is no one and I mean no one will
outwork her she will find story like
she's exhausting to be around because
she's she's gonna track down whatever
the information is by the way fritzy
does it a pretty good Andrea Kramer let
me let you grade this Hannah here's Todd
fridge
thank you Dan I got a chance to speak
with Case Keenum as the Broncos get
ready to host Patrick my Holmes and the
Chiefs and it should be a dandy in the
AFC West this coming Monday night with
the Broncos I'm Joe Kramer
yes is great about this for my dear
Andrea who I adore and love is that
she's talking so much on the fly and she
she remembers so much he's very very
smart and so it's cool because you see
her you know just really sit there and
like like break you know break down
what's happening on the screen and she
has all these notes she has an entire
wall covered with all this incredible
resource you've known and all these
conversations because you know she has
to just remember it and look at the
television which is cool which I've
always loved that I love life I mean
come on so do you you know that's that's
just a blast but where are you when
you're broadcasting this so you're not
in Los Angeles my gosh we're in you know
we're in like guards basement I mean
we're literally
like you know a little room in in
Sanford Connecticut and we're there
across the hall from us are the are the
UK guys and next to us are the Spanish
broadcasters and it's really funny
because before the game you can hear
everybody you know talking in their
accents and different languages about
different things and you know watching a
pregame show and it's hysterical it's
actually really really cool people had a
really hard time finding it last night
so yes the people were complaining about
that you really have to go to the audio
setting it all comes emanates from the
live feed from Fox you have to go to the
audio settings and like click which
audio setting you want to watch them
obviously and watch you know I mean Joe
and Troy or you know the best at what
they do
so we're not you know we're trying to be
those guys they're really being
ourselves that that's like the simplest
way I can put it obviously I mean
they've been at that for decades it's a
very very pinnacle of their career and
this isn't us trying to be like them or
Alan Chris or you know anybody like that
this is us being us and you know talking
about the game from our perspective and
you know Amazon is able to gauge
audience reaction in real time which is
really cool right and they got a big a
really positive reaction so it's pretty
psyched you know for the first game out
and then and then we have ten more you
know so we're probably going to be a
home let's hope so let me pray that we
are you know light years better by the
end of this well congrats you got to do
it yeah you got to get reps that's the
right just bungee jump you know just go
and yeah yeah well congrats it good to
visit with you again Hannah thanks for
joining us EP you're the best
Hannah Storm for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
you
[Music]